nashville tennessee lexington kentucky
thank you so much for all the love it
was great to see you all out there i
really appreciate all the support i am
bringing the night pants nation tour to
boston march 31st to april 2nd
and minneapolis april 28th through the
30th get your tickets for those shows
and all shows at ryansickler.com
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media i can't thank you enough
for your support it's been a hell of a
year so far we're going to continue that
run please subscribe to the youtube
channel uh it's a huge help to
everything we do over here and the
patreon it's called the honeydew with
you all i'm highlighting the lowlights
with y'all the stories are unlike
anything you've ever heard i promise you
that it's five bucks a month if you sign
up for a year you're getting over a
month free and you're getting the honey
do a day early ad-free at no additional
cost all right that's the biz right
there you guys know we do over here
we're highlighting the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers all right
ladies and gentlemen it is a pleasure to
have the legend back the one and only
joey diaz everybody welcome back to the
honeydew joey diaz
what's going on ryan cichlid the
russians are coming
goddammit they are boy how about that
ghost of kiev
dan van kirk told me about this guy last
night he's called i think it's the ghost
of kiev they call him and he's a fighter
jet that shot down six russian jets
yesterday alone and they can't get this
guy they can't see him but he's like the
red baron up there right now and our
times this dude's like a badass and he's
knocking him all out of the sky and they
can't [ __ ] with him up there he's like
he's like the tony hawk of [ __ ]
fighter pilots
what a [ __ ] nightmare my friend for
real we just got over it now we gotta
[ __ ] the world war three yeah after code
it's coming over coven's over though
isn't it seems like it now jesus christ
nobody gives a [ __ ] seriously they're
bombing people we gotta worry about a
mask
that's it they're not talking about
vaccines no more nothing
i heard they're letting people into new
york without the car you know
it's over of course
listen there's no way the united states
of america is gonna tell people that you
can't [ __ ] come here and and you know
save your [ __ ] self there's gonna be
a lot of looking left and right when it
comes to that [ __ ] blind eyes and yeah
yeah compassionate souls
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do they're
they're they're capitals getting bombed
they bomb the airport they bomb the air
imagine being in la right now you're
like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
and here like they bombed lax you're
like how am i getting the [ __ ] out now
i gotta drive to vegas burbank or some
[ __ ]
all right brother we have not done one
of these since july of 2021 when we last
ended
it was uh it's actually very touching to
me now because it was march of 97 for
you i had just moved here on valentine's
day in in 97 and you just got passed at
the store
and for me i'm sitting here right now
i'm newly passed at the store so it's
nice to by the way it's nice to be able
to go on that wall with you someday joey
diaz it's uh it was 25 years
the anniversary was 25 years
last saturday it was on my birthday
i became a
on my birthday okay
it all came together you know yeah you
you were mentioning that you went in you
didn't want to touch the toilet with
your hands so you [ __ ] sat the lid
down and you sat there and you cried and
it just all came out everything from
back in denver back in jersey new york
all of it
prison all of it coming back to you and
it just hit now you're a [ __ ] regular
at the world famous comedy store so
let's pick up march of 97
and we'll go from there
you know the next day i woke up and i'll
have to tell you how i felt
i felt invincible
i felt that i belonged
and i'm happy that i got to do this now
because
it's given me and i've been doing stand
up it's going to be a year now it was a
year yesterday or something
since i haven't been on stage so it's
given me a lot of
time to think you know and
the the best times i had yet it felt
great to sell out theaters and
it felt great to sell out comedy clubs
that was great
felt great the shooter special
but there's nothing better than getting
accepted
into the circle that you're
you know that you're going for that's a
great feeling you know i started in
denver
and then i went to new york from nine to
ten months
which taught me how to kind of start up
in the city and get the party started
then i went back to denver
and got the party started there for a
year
and then i went to seattle
and got the party started there
so by the time you get to that fourth
destination
you know how to get the party started
you know
by that time i had joined an acting
class on monday night
jamie masada told me i wasn't funny
enough to do his stage [ __ ] that guy
but i had a guy who worked there who
used to give me a 20-minute spot every
monday for latino night
and it was packed
and you know
it's so weird people think you make it
at the store and that's it
no that's when your work starts this i
just did the
comedy store podcast last night with
eleanor and she said the same thing i
said look it's it's great you're right
there's not there i i'm so surprised the
camaraderie and um how kind everyone has
been coming up to me and congratulating
me and stuff you know i i didn't expect
first of all i don't expect anything
from anybody but i really didn't expect
that i have been in that building
for so long doing so many shows just
never a regular
that
it really they i see how much they
appreciate it so it is something to be
accepted by
this band of [ __ ] misfits and you
know you're one of us now i really feel
good about that but you're right a
15-minute set at the comedy store
is that's a that's all it is it does not
make you a comedian an hour makes you a
comedian if you can go on the road and
sell tickets it makes you a comedian
like just being a comedy store comic is
awesome but it does there's so much more
and you're right that's where your work
begins now you got to go to that next
level
and you've seen guys over the years do
it prior murphy robin williams just name
them all of them you know
it's so busy out it's so weird how when
you go to jiu jitsu
or karate when you start you're in the
back of the class
and then after three months you move up
six spots
and then after three years you're in the
front line you know
and it's the same thing at the comedy
store like i remember getting made
and getting passed not to to get away
from this
after i got passed like
once somebody became a regular we'd wait
for them on the stairs and when they
come out we treat them like
the guys in good fellas
yeah yeah yeah
when simone got passed
and we did that to him you got made oh
[ __ ]
after your cherry and we hugged you
not for me for me nobody just said dick
to me but i remember the next day
i got up and i went and brought scott
dead bala tequila
he was the talent coordinator at the
store
and i had a weekend that weekend when
she made me on a sunday
and that following weekend i had a
weekend in san francisco
and somebody told me dog cancel that
[ __ ]
because you don't want to get made and
then disappear on her and then she
forgets about you
so i cancelled it
and my goal at that time
was to become a good comedian
but to be honest here the way you have
to think when you walk into the candy
store
or the improv regardless of what you
think
or what's happened to you in your life
you have to go i'm gonna
i'm gonna give myself five years i'm
gonna be the best comic up here
you know you gotta sink in
get involved at the store do all the
belly room shows
for people the more exposure that's
right so my world had become the comedy
story
i was you know
the felonies got expunged
that expunged everything that was
what when was that
in 97 also
97 yeah no no i'm saying that the
becoming a regular
took away all the sins got it
it took away a lot of the pain you know
it took away a lot of things
now my [ __ ] goal was to become the
best at the store you know
to move up the ladder from the one
o'clock spot
to 10 15.
you know and i'll never forget monday i
got a spot
that monday my first monday they gave me
a spot
like at 11 o'clock boy was i [ __ ]
happy
i got josh wolfe i got my other buddies
i got i got
brody everybody came down to see my spot
monday night
comedy store debut
ready to [ __ ] go
and all of a sudden
eddie griffith taps me and he goes hey
player
do you mind if i do 10 minutes in front
of you yeah
don't you stay down to a quarter or two
yeah i know
i don't know if maddie griffin's ever
done 10 minutes
[Laughter]
went from the biggest high in my life
to the biggest low in my life did you
still get to go
if you would have come by and [ __ ] me in
the ass
it would have been the best thing you
could have done
i was just sitting back there
ready to cry and my friends kept saying
goodbye one by one yeah yeah let it go
man
we'll see you next time and i'm like
[ __ ]
and then finally eddie griffin goes hey
you coming up here cuba and i remember
walking up there like ready to shoot
myself
i wanted to kill him i think i went home
and cried again you go from this biggest
high
for this gigantic [ __ ] low in 24
hours
and that was okay it teaches you it
teaches you
i was used to it already you know
getting bumped and people telling me
they're gonna do ten minutes and they're
up there for two hours so then
you know i didn't have a i had a
girlfriend
we were kind of at war you know we had
found a place in hollywood and
it was getting myself
familiarized i got an acting class
on uh on monday nights over on gardner
on the other side of
sunset behind the guitar center yeah
get what the guy's name was because
after like three weeks on monday it was
it was seven to ten
and after about three or four weeks
the guy said to me
by the way is anybody comedian here and
i didn't say [ __ ]
and he goes i hate [ __ ] comedians
you guys come in here you think you're
the cream of the croc i can't stand them
the last comic i dealt with was [ __ ]
andrew dice clay and he put a left a bad
taste in my mouth i was like [ __ ]
now he's doing woody allen movies
so monday nights
was the busiest night in hollywood at
the time
they were [ __ ] you know
it was the last factory latino night
back
crazy monday whatever it was at the
improv back
and the comedy store had an open mic but
after 10 you go down there and sign up
on monday so your goal
was to get a triple crown on monday
nights
to get a spot at the improv to get a
spot at the lab factory so for months i
would get spots
every [ __ ] monday at the laugh
factory with gilbert
felipe willie barcena
carlos mancilla pablo francisco
carlos oscar that was that crew
and then i would go to the comedy store
and hang out you know
a couple i was hanging out in the
daytime with doug stanhope
i would go to doug's house and write
with him
and try to learn what the [ __ ] he was
doing because he was on a different
level
in 97 he had
turned the face of comedy and that's
what i wanted to do i wanted to switch
it up a little bit from the [ __ ] hey
how you doing you know i'm saying all
that [ __ ]
so
i was hanging out with doug in the
daytime and then that circle became
doug and mitch
so it was me doug and mitch hedberg
would meet at like two
at doug stanhopes on curson
and then we'd walk to gorky park
consulting the russian park i'm gonna
say yeah i'm gonna say this that's three
very different voices of comedy getting
together unlike anything especially at
that time even still now it's it's still
yeah
especially mitch hedberg too he's still
one of a kind he is still one-of-a-kind
was already in montreal yeah people know
mitch was doug heck was
tearing up the country
and i was like a feature act learning
from the both of them
just listening to them talk and we would
play tennis
that's when he wrote that joke
i'll never be as good as the wall
he was a [ __ ] he was and then he
added to that
he lived next to he lived on sierra
bonita next to [ __ ] nick de
paulo they were neighbors and nick
wasn't crazy about mitch hedberg because
yeah i could see that yeah and the
guitar playing so
uh nick would bang on the wall and mitch
would tell us
you know that [ __ ] knicks in a bad
mood today you know whatever
but it was something that
like i said you could hang out with pry
and all this [ __ ]
that camaraderie will never happen again
yeah
gosh wolf was in the circle a lot i was
a lot with josh in her vase
doug stanhope lived on kirsan
mitch hedberg and
nick lived on sierra bonita
and then there was gardner
and there was a friend of doug stanhope
who lived on garden
and then vista was joshua
so four blocks in a row i would just
wake up in the morning go from door to
door
you know i didn't i wasn't tight friends
with the guy who lived on gardner
but one day there was an emergency and
he had to leave
and there was a fat guy staying over
with joey medina that was a funny guy
he was friends with doug stanhope so
doug stanton opened him in that building
now and that was ralphie may no way
so now it was
it was josh
ralphie
nick
mitch
and doug stanhope five blocks in a row
that's nice
i know when i when i first moved here in
94 we used to get a male it was off of
sweets or sweets are in fountain right
there you know
and we would get mailed it would say
andrew silverstein
and it ended up that that was one of
dice's old apartments and that was well
i didn't know until i was a fan it was
andrew i believe it was andrew clay
silverstein i think's his real name i
think it is and we used to get his
[ __ ] mail and that
it hit me i was like am i really coming
here to be a comedian and i'm in one of
dice's old places like that just it just
was a one of those things like wow
because you you knew they all lived in
that area if they could there's the
stores there the improvs here and the
left that's that triangle it's a little
[ __ ] triangle right there
all within what like a mile mile and a
half of each other tops
well josh wolf lived in the apartment
where
sandler's partner
lived when he first moved to l.a no [ __ ]
yeah
he was getting residual checks from that
guy
for three grand two grand all coming to
his place
[Laughter]
the guy was a missile but what up
i was broke
at that time i had a little bit of money
left from a deal
i got from cbs and i basically moved to
l.a
to fulfill this deal it was a show on
cbs
called bronx county
and uh
after about a month of being in la
becoming a regular i mean you got to
remember i became a regular
in l.a in less than a month it's still
uh that's amazing
amazing that's a [ __ ] story i i
wonder if you might not be the fastest
uh ever
i won you got to be up there you got to
be up there yep yeah i mean some like
rudy moreno
was doing a spot for mitzi in the main
room for latino night and mitzi made him
a regular [ __ ] like that
but there's usually like a point that
you go up there
and you gotta you know hang out before
you become a regular
i was there maybe five nights before i
became a regular at that
at that point in my life i didn't have
the mental capacity
to hang out if i'm not working i'm not
there
i always said there's no reason to go to
a club and hang out because if you do
meet somebody
they're going to ask you when are you
going up and you're going to go not
tonight i'm going up at
auntie chang's dumpling palace you know
what the [ __ ] are you doing here
so that's why i never really i'm not
everybody always says you got to hang
out and talk to people [ __ ] you
you want to talk to somebody join a
lonely arts club i'm going out at night
to do spots and i remember that every
day i would [ __ ] call people to give
me spots like
you know a couple people had rooms in
the orange county
but the most noticeable guy was rudy
moreno yeah he roomed at the brave bull
like the comedy store
it was basically three [ __ ] rooms
and he would book three rooms on a
saturday and friday
i must have called them for a [ __ ]
month
so i was blowing the [ __ ] face and he
wouldn't return my calls
so i borrowed a car one night and i
actually went to the brave bull
and i go who's rudy [ __ ] miranda
and i go how [ __ ] day you not call me
back
i could see if i was some white animal
or something i'm spanish
[Laughter]
and he's like okay okay i'll put you up
i love i love it he's great too
i did a lot of his shows at the ice
house early on coming up he he he really
did hustle and booked a lot of shows
gave a lot of comedians uh spots if
you're waiting for the right time to buy
your first home i've got news for you
things are only getting crazier rents
and house prices are skyrocketing
interest rates are going up and no
matter what stage you're in you should
start planning now i look every night
out here i check zillow i check westside
rentals i check apartments.com i check
craigslist i check all of them rents are
insane the cost of living is insane okay
i recommend that everyone listen to the
how to buy a home podcast this is an
incredible free resource with everything
you need to know to navigate this
process host david sidone is an industry
expert with years of experience who
actually cares about first-time home
buyers like you and he answers questions
like when is the best time to start how
do i even start will a mortgage be more
than my current monthly rent probably
not and the good news is he just
released an emergency episode of how to
buy a home all about the bidding wars of
2022 with insider tips and tricks to win
david has helped make buying a home a
reality for so many people he even
connects first-time home buyers with
great local realtors in their area so
they know they have someone in their
corner i'm telling you he can help you
too he's already helped a couple you
guys out there so listen to the how to
buy a home podcast today david can help
find how to buy a home wherever you
listen to podcasts for many people
getting financially healthy means
dropping the weight of credit card debt
but where do you start when it feels
like a never ending cycle right upstart
can help you pay off your existing debt
quickly and easily with a personal loan
so you can start living your life
whether it's paying off your credit
cards consolidating that high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model it considers other
factors like your income your employment
and other information provided in your
loan application to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in just five minutes for loans between a
thousand all the way up to 50 000 and
you can even receive your funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
your income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
dog you used to give me three spots a
week i used to torture him and work them
[Laughter]
while he was on stage i'd sit behind the
stage and go rudy
rudy
rudy
rudy i was just rude
but that particular night
about a year and a half
well maybe like three years earlier
i was at the comedy works i did the open
mic
and the guy that was in charge of comedy
works was a [ __ ] sweetheart who
actually changed my life around
i did a spot i killed
three minutes you know
and he chased me outside this guy and he
goes can i talk to you for a second he
goes listen
we both know
you're the funniest guy here without
even blinking a [ __ ] eye
but you don't take it seriously
because look at the t-shirt you got on
you don't come to another writing
classes
you're not involved with us at all you
just come in
blow the room up and [ __ ] leave
that's great that'll work but it ain't
gonna work for a while not for the long
run you gotta write jokes blah blah blah
and he told me he goes
you know
you're a good comic but this isn't what
you want to do
you're not putting the right work in you
should just quit
if you don't want to do this and i
remember i had my hands clenched
i was ready to knock this [ __ ]
out like look at this guy telling me
and i walked over to the bus and i go
you know what i am gonna [ __ ] him up
and i walked back to the comedy works in
denver and i went downstairs and he
wasn't there and i remember i took a bus
home
and a month later i got thrown out of
the comedy workshop it didn't matter
that dude i bumped into him that night
at rudy's
he was a guy that worked with all the
comics and helped him
at this time he was working with brian
dunkleman yeah
and he was bringing brian down before
american idol i don't know what it was
so i went up on stage and i had a follow
on like a top headliner
he's gone now tommy
drake or something
tommy something he used to be like a
detective
i like my women how i like my coffee
with two tits all that [ __ ] you know
i think you know
i never heard that
he was a funny dude i had seen
evening at the improv a bunch of times
even long detective jacket like a hat
yeah you know all that type of
i was talking to this dane
he blew up the [ __ ] room i was my
knees but then i said to myself [ __ ]
this
i'm at the comedy story [ __ ] night
following savages at the time they
weren't the savages there were when i
was there but they were sabbaties you
know to be at the store after 10 30. you
got to be a [ __ ] savage
and and brother i went up there and took
that room apart at the brave bull limb
by [ __ ] limb
and i got off and rudy goes you come
down whatever the [ __ ] you want just
clean it up a little bit
and as i passed by rudy i saw that guy
matt that was his name matt
and he goes what the [ __ ] was that
and at that point i accepted what he
said to me and i pulled him aside
and i go you don't know how lucky you
were that night of losing a [ __ ]
i'm a [ __ ] nut and you destroyed me
that night as a human being
but when i got home i thought about what
your words were and you were right
and you're the reason why i'm here
tonight so thank you
and he gave me a big hug and i never saw
him again matt
woods
great comic
he came up with matt berry roseanne
uh
todd jordan rick kearns
they were [ __ ] you know when
when uh one of the country guys uh larry
the cable guy
wanted material he bought all the denver
comics materials oh is that right
yeah they were great writers
all those guys uh written house with the
hook
yeah they got the hook up on stage
[ __ ] brilliant writer that
[ __ ]
uh so it was great it was great to see
him and
but after i saw that guy and after i
knew i could do it
because before you come to l.a you hear
all these negative things from comics
when you go on the road
you know don't go to l.a you got to be a
[ __ ] you got to suck dick nobody will put
you on stage
here i am three [ __ ] months and i'm
getting loved everywhere i got love at
the improv
before i got love at the store
i was already getting spot there was a
guy there named cooper who was the
talent coordinator who was a drunk great
guy
and he saw me do a latino night and he
made me a regular
and that now he's in at the laugh
factory so it was
i was rocking and [ __ ] rolling three
months in
now it's time to shoot the pilot
the director of this pilot for cbs
they gave 3 million dollars so i thought
this show
was definitely going to work you know
the director was the guy who played the
doctor in jail
when the guy from the sopranos was in
prison
wait remember remember johnny sack went
to prison johnny sack yeah
but johnny sack was in prison there was
a guy with glasses
that was [ __ ] making his bed and all
that [ __ ] that's the thing
that guy is a bad asthma he's also in
eyes wide shut that dude
he's been in a thousand things he
directed it
so when i got there i was playing a
bartender
that
had uh
he gave information to the cops
he was the eyes and ears of the
neighborhood
he was a spanish guy in the bronx you
know
and i remember going to the rehearsals
and every time i would say a word or i'd
act
people would shake their head
i was bad ryan sickler
so it was like two weeks of rehearsals
every time
my lines got shorter
wait hold on you would see them shake
their heads when you would do your life
that's brutal seeing him out there just
like god there it was terrible
you know i had never acted before
i'd probably taken
three or four acting classes by then
i was a lot better than a lot of other
people
because i watched a lot of tv but
so every time i went in like monday when
i got there it was nine pages besides
when i got that tuesday was down to
eight
wednesday there was eight again but it
was because they erased words and they
made me just act like a [ __ ] deaf
mute like hmm
like you know
changing um whole character now oh i
mean i went deaf in like [ __ ] two
weeks
by the last week i was down to like two
lines like what are you drinking
what are you drinking that's all this
[ __ ]
oh my god i was so [ __ ] bad
and for the guys
to let you know man you gotta work at it
you know and i remember by the time we
shot the pilot
the [ __ ] they were down to one line
like what do you guys have
that was it
and there was rumors that the show got
picked up they weren't gonna pick me up
they were gonna rehire somebody else
that's when i started stealing wardrobes
and [ __ ]
well i know i'm not coming back i start
stealing shirts and underwear
i was living on cocaine so i either
bought underwear
i did everything [ __ ] commando i had
holes in my socks i didn't give a [ __ ]
i'm snorting coke and i'm being a comic
by the time i shot that pilot i was down
to one [ __ ] line
and i remember at the end when i was
leaving everybody was talking to me
they're like yeah
see you and everybody else is saying see
you soon not me
good luck
i left that [ __ ] crap
so i said [ __ ] it i had this crazy
girlfriend the stripper that used to let
me choke her and light her [ __ ]
so i was up in their house up in the
valley but
at that time josh wolfe gave me a car
that belonged to a casting director that
she lent it to him while she was out of
town and i started getting tickets on
this [ __ ] all right
i was getting tickets all over hollywood
that little black chick what the [ __ ]
was chasing me all over hollywood you
know what's what i'm talking about in
the white car that [ __ ] is angry
it's the [ __ ] nixon administration
i'm driving this chick's car
and i'm getting tickets everywhere i got
camouflage on the car i'm putting leaves
on it in [ __ ] hollywood i'd come out
of somewhere i'd still get a [ __ ]
ticket
i probably had 50 [ __ ] tickets
and i go up to this girl's house the
pilot
they just give me like 10 grand for the
[ __ ] week
i'm gonna go see my girlfriend up there
well she wasn't my girlfriend at the
time
we had dated for four years now we were
just [ __ ] she was a dirty [ __ ] but i
loved it what are you gonna do
and uh
i'm in there we took a shower i gave her
a stab in the shower
and when i came out my car was towed
i was told
and they told that lady's car and they
just said my car
oh without a [ __ ] without a title
so they took everything they took my
[ __ ] my house got towed because at
the time i was just living in my car
ralphie
and they used to say your house got cold
[ __ ]
everything headshots
demo reels [ __ ] clothes
boxing gloves a frisbee
all right wait i have to stop you for a
second because segura told me the story
and it's i'm jumping way forward because
you're talking about how bad you were at
acting but
you you did the sopranos movie
uh and i just want to hear this story
real quick i i think it was segora that
told me this about your scene with de
niro you had a scene with the nero
yeah and did he just
you were you were pretty like holy [ __ ]
i'm sitting here with [ __ ] bobby de
niro
that was grudge match oh it was on
grudge match he did that
tell me that stuff because we're talking
let's real quick let's give you some
love because go from watching people
shake their heads at you delivering your
lines to having
uh a scene with deniro i said sopranos
grudge match tell me what did he say to
you when you sat with him because what
are you sitting across from him
yeah well there was a couple things you
know he
deniro don't say much
you know you got to beat him to get
something out of him
so like i don't know what story he told
you because i don't know about this i
know
i know he touched her hand like i know i
know that one
yeah what happened is you know i went
when i got to new orleans i got there
and i always read that gene hackman
would always go straight to the set he
would never go in his in his dressing
room and i thought that was interesting
and i read something by gene ackman
that said he wanted to always be close
to the action
you know so when i got the
new orleans i packed my [ __ ] in the room
and i ran out of there and i went to
wardrobe
and then from there i go where's the set
and i they go down the block we'll give
you a ride they go you're not shooting i
would just want to go see you know and
when i got there it was llc
and he was in the thing they were
getting ready and also de niro came in
and hello kuji and they were hugging
each other you know they're hugging and
kissing and [ __ ] telling each other
stories i'm 30 feet away
i'm just watching bro trying to learn
something
and they're like all right let's jump
let's do this guys and
they talk in 20 minutes you know
they say action manero walks up the
[ __ ] hello cool j
and hello cool j starts stuttering like
[ __ ] you know
like spider
cut
action let's do it again action second
take again
[ __ ] i can't remember my lines cut
you know and it was and i noticed that i
go what the [ __ ] was that
i mean hello cool j was rehearsing when
i got here they rehearsed the scene like
five times
what is going on i i didn't think about
it the next day i get there
and sure enough i sit down in the chair
and they come over they go you meet out
you know you meet bobby yeah i met him
and analyzed that i shake his hand how
are you doing good to see you
you want to rehearse one time yeah we
rehearsed one time it's just one [ __ ]
line
and
it went smoother than [ __ ]
and the next time sure enough
action the cameras are on
he comes up to me bro and i look at his
face
and you just don't see bob mirror
you see jimmy conway
yeah the guy from taxi driver you see
the guy from right now
raging bull you see the guy
but with the hunting movie when he goes
to vietnam
get christopher walken you know you see
this guy and all of a sudden you just
[ __ ] like
it's like you fizz out like you just
hear the plug get pulled
you don't know who the [ __ ] it is
and i was really
i was very self-conscious
i go hey
robin i'm sorry and he's like grabbed my
hand he's like i know
i know it's gonna be all right
he knows he knows everybody brothers and
[ __ ] he knows that you're sitting here
with robert [ __ ] de niro and it's
gonna take you a minute but don't
because it's into him with a thousand
people amazing that's reaction so he'll
like break it down later don't worry
about it
you know i'm like
i've done it with names who are [ __ ]
practical
because once you see his face
you just you don't even know what line
to go yeah
you know goldman gets your shine box you
don't know what the [ __ ]
really [ __ ] interesting and then i
you know after that movie
i got into a high-end acting class i got
into advantage of
because she had just won a
academy award with holly berry and then
she won one the next year with charlize
theron
so everybody said she was really good
and she was very good for character acts
you know
it was weird because
when you first moved to hollywood
you win some pretty big battles but as
you know
you lose
pretty big battles oh yeah
and my internal battle at that time was
i couldn't get representation
i had a manager when i first got to town
great guy this is i want to take his
business after your house was stolen
you're still
having trouble getting representation
and all this stuff then
yeah i was having a hard time
i had this guy ken phillips for a while
ken was a good guy in fact
when i first got to the store like three
weeks into the store i don't know what's
going on
i'm [ __ ] flat broke i'm living
handsome out you know
and there's two [ __ ] wannabe guidos
at the store
talking about their bookmaking
right they're bookmakers blah blah blah
you know
i think they were friends with one of
the italian guys up there
and they're like if you ever want to put
in the action you know let us know
here's our number and i go sure you know
i never thought about it one day i need
money to do coke that weekend
and i'm like i like this [ __ ] game
tonight if i could just get a book and i
go oh [ __ ] i know a book those guys they
lived on la cienega right before you hit
santa monica boulevard so i called them
up i love you remember yeah
the cuban kid how are you doing yeah
good i go listen i want to put in i put
in like a 250 bet
if i won i collect if i lose i tend to
go [ __ ] yourself you know this was
and i didn't want to do this in l.a i
didn't want to bring that part of my
world
into la you know but i
i needed money and i did and i [ __ ]
put the bed in on a monday night it was
houston
i love this you always remember this go
ahead tell them
like 25 you couldn't even write this
[ __ ]
so the next day i called the guys and i
go hey i want to collect and they go
come by you know like okay and i go down
there
and the guy says uh what we're gonna do
is just give you 50 bucks
like what are you talking about
it's 250 it was i forget what it was
and he goes well we charge you
a hundred dollar fee to join us
and then hundred dollar deposit
you know
and then you're good for the season
you know and i'm like what the [ __ ] are
you guys talking about
and they go this is the way we do it if
you don't like you get the [ __ ] out of
here
like oh really and i went right next
door ken phillips lived like the
building next door right by the 7-eleven
across the southern eleven and last year
again there's a it's a school in there
they used no there still is hollywood
and i'll never
forget went over to ken phillips house
and he had like a nine millimeter
and i go ken i need to borrow your gun
he goes for what
i go i want to shoot a scene for a a
movie i want them they want me to shoot
it he goes what movie i haven't heard
from nobody i'll tell you tomorrow let
me just shoot this scene i got to walk
out of a car and point a gun in the
bushes
that wasn't why i needed the gun
i was going next door i'd have no
bullets in the gun so i'm like this is
going to get [ __ ] up you know
i walk next door i knock on the door the
guy's like what do you want
i [ __ ] rip out the gun
i go listen man i've been putting bets
in for 30 [ __ ] years
nobody has ever asked me for a [ __ ]
deposit or a [ __ ] feet a member [ __ ]
i want my 200 islands i was shooting it
out
and this [ __ ] dog i was more
scared than ever
i thought these guys were gonna shoot me
the one kid basically started crying
crying
basically started crying i was like
jesus
this [ __ ] california is filled with
guy had tattoos gold chains
you know he was the mafia he barely
started [ __ ] crying
please put it away i'll give you the
money i gave the money because you're
never allowed to bet with us again i i
better not see you at the story
you [ __ ] thieves that's how crazy i
was when i got to the store and then
it's slow you know
i didn't want to [ __ ] up in california
but in the in my heart
i thought that
my plan for california was simple
this is it
i'm gonna stay here till i fail so bad
that i gotta leave like everywhere else
i lived
you know you believed you were gonna
fail did you really believe that here
though
yes you did
even though i was a regular at the store
and had all those things going for me
trust me i've had a ton of things going
for me before
i've been known to blow [ __ ]
but for some reason
i didn't want to blow this
you know i was a [ __ ] street hustler
i could make
i'd get anything
i could sell you anything on the street
so if i pull up to get a check and i see
five cases of jack daniels
i just [ __ ] see a colombian you know
what i'm saying like i would just see a
colombian with a mink jacket on you know
i never stole nothing from the store
i never
i never really wanted to cause and i got
the fistfights up there
i bombed a lot up there like i still
remember in the beginning
getting in my car and just crying and
driving on sunset
and going that's the last time i'll be
doing a spot there
once mitzy hears about that bombing
she's gonna [ __ ] you know i'm not
good enough
but sure enough the next week
i would get a [ __ ] call you know
whether it's saving more and spending
less getting organized or losing weight
there's a lot of worthwhile goals to set
for yourself this year and at the top of
my list is learning a new language with
babel the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
i'm working on my espanol right now and
it's going muy bueno y'all not only is
learning a new language a fun and
engaging new hobby you can use it while
you're traveling the whole babel process
is addictively fun fast and easy babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use right look for me
learning is repetition and the thing i
love about babel is that you'll they'll
give you a lesson and then you'll redo
it you'll write it you'll speak it
you'll go over it you'll learn your
accent all of it okay babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over a hundred language experts their
teaching method has been scientifically
proven to be effective and with babel
you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish french
italian and german plus babel speech
recognition technology helps you to
improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babylon additional lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
so just go to babel.com
use my promo code honeydew all right
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code honeydew babel language for life
today's program is brought to you by
athletic greens the health and wellness
company that makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really really simple with so
many stressors in life it's difficult to
maintain effective nutritional habits
and give our bodies the nutrients it
needs to thrive we've got busy schedules
we're getting poor sleep exercise the
environment work stress or simply not
eating enough of the right foods can
leave us deficient in key nutritional
areas i use a scoop of ag-1 every day i
take a little packet actually i throw it
in my water boom i'm good for the day i
love it one tasty scoop of ag-1 contains
75 vitamins minerals and
whole-food-sourced ingredients including
a multi-vitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more in one
convenient daily serving the special
blend of high quality bioavailable
ingredients and a scoop of ag-1 work
together to fill the nutritional gaps in
your diet support energy and focus aid
with gut health and digestion and
support a healthy immune system
effectively replacing multiple products
or pills with one healthy delicious
drink join the movement of athletes moms
dads rookies first timers and everyone
in between taking ownership of their
daily health and focusing on the
nutritional products they really need in
the simplest manner possible to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you an immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give ag-1 a try now let's get back
to the deal when i moved to l.a
immediately i got a manager
that was a low-rank guy sweetheart of a
guy
he was just getting he was new
you know and that's the biggest struggle
he had
and i also had a great commercial agent
the best ones i had sutton bartomenari
and this was all taken care of
like in the first
six months that i was here
i had sutton barton inari i had a
manager
and i was a regular at all three clubs
and i didn't really [ __ ] know where i
was going you know you're just trying to
figure out i'm talking to agents every
night i'm watching them at clubs
talking to other people watching these
other [ __ ] stiff comics
so one day i got a call from sutton
martin and ari and they want to start
sending me out for commercial auditions
they made me do like an hour workshop at
the agency
and they started sending me out my first
audition was for church's chicken
on sunset boulevard yeah
i i you know again you're so naive
you think you're gonna [ __ ] get
something you know and
i kept going auditions they i don't in
those days
ryan you were going to three commercial
auditions a day
that's how different the the budget was
back then like times were
you were going on three commercial
auditions a day
you were probably hitting 13 auditions a
week
and maybe
two theatrical auditions a week
that is what it was
i would get a call friday
that i had a commercial audition monday
at 11.
by the time i was leaving that audition
on monday
he would call me another audition
115
go to whatever and go show them this
oh you got a 5 15 downtown l.a it was
it was [ __ ] amazing and we didn't
know how lucky we were we had no idea
that that was as good as it was gonna
get ever gonna get yeah ever gonna get
we were complaining that i can't book
nothing
and i kept going i kept going i kept
going auditions
i had already a tv show under my belt
but i hadn't i couldn't get an audition
for a movie and
well i'm lying to you judy brown
called me in for an audition for the
jenny mccarthy show
to be chas mom and terry's driver
okay
she just thanked me for coming in thank
you
that means you suck yeah yeah
i'm not mad at judy brown she thought of
me and i had to audition for a uh
robert de niro movie with marky warburg
it was uh
the vinnie curtis story
and i'll never forget that vinnie
curtail gave me a line on her and i was
so aggressive back then like i wanted to
go in for an audition that every sunday
night i would write her a letter by hand
with a picture and a resume
and
tickets to the comedy store and the
improv
and i would tell i would have spots
there during the week call up you know
and i'll never forget when i finally
went in to see her
after i
died in the [ __ ] room you know i
didn't know what i was doing she goes oh
by the way
ryan
can i tell you that she actually gave me
a box of letters
i have
sent her
a box of letters
she could it was just [ __ ] folders i
would send to the eight by tens
she gave me a box back
how many i gave her there must have been
40 envelopes
she opened up the first one didn't open
up the wrestler
she told me that was very aggressive and
that's good that you're doing that she
goes i'm not mad at you but some people
will get mad at you but keep doing that
i met a mental note you know
so finally i get a [ __ ] call from
sutton martin ari
and they want me to read for this
[ __ ] tremendous he was like the
director of the year for sag for
commercials
and he was shooting uh a taco bell
commercial
in [ __ ]
miami so i'm like what
i get to shoot a commercial get paid
get my dicks up and start some cocaine
i'm [ __ ] in
so i go down i'll never forget i went
down on a thursday
and they [ __ ] love me they called me
back on friday
i went down there on friday and rocked
them and they called me right after that
and they said you're working monday
uh fourth of july you get double rate
whatever
kiska was his name or something
he goes you booked a role as a taxi
driver
all right
so saturday i had to go to wardrobe they
paid me for that i stole a t-shirt you
know yeah
i used to love wardrobe because i would
steal everything right
so
[Laughter]
oh so uh
yeah they called me monday seven o'clock
call
down at abbott kenny in uh marina del
rey yeah
and we're there by the park if they
built something on it now it used to be
a park and down the corner was uh
the [ __ ] pizza on the bagel bread and
[ __ ] it's still there
good pizza down there anyway
i get down there monday morning and
their weight fun
and they pull me aside and they go joey
we're really sorry about this
uh you did great
but
out of the three commercials your
commercial got can't ah
but they go listen never fear
sit here for three days
we're gonna give you two thousand bucks
for the three days you know
680 a day whatever they pay you plus
overtime
eat off food and go home on wednesday
all right don't get mad
you know you can read whatever you want
you can take a walk do whatever [ __ ] you
want i was like you're getting a paid
vacation now
yeah i was a little depressed yeah
so not 10 minutes after that a guy comes
up to me sweetheart of a guy his name is
buzz bae mundo
no
old-school comic from the comedy store
in fact he had move on
he was there with mitzi in the [ __ ]
beginning
he knew everybody you know
his wife was an agent and he was a
writer
and he had taken to writing so
you know
he was just doing commercials and stuff
like that
he becomes my friend on the set
and he's got a commercial
a taco bell they're shooting three of
them but now we're down to two
it's the first ones ever with the dog
yeah yo quiero taco bell that one yeah
first ones ever
so monday i go down there work today i'm
going back home going to the comedy
store
just being happy that i'm shooting
something you know
tuesday i go there
i'm bullshitting with everybody at
lunchtime i'm [ __ ] telling stories at
the lunch table cracking jokes
director grabs me after lunch and he
goes hey man
stay close to me
all day
want you to change and stay close to me
because i left the wardrobe in your room
because i got a spot in this commercial
i want to see if we can get you in there
nice
so there was also another comedian i
forget his great guy he was a sag extra
on the job which is not a bad job it's
300 a day to be a sag extra
so we're talking with [ __ ] the
director comes over joey get in the
scene and i get in the scene i'm there
playing dominoes in the scene
buzz is in the scene
and the guy is shining my shoes
was supposed to be in miami
the guys i got white shoes on the whole
thing
i shoot with them we have a great time
the dog walks by
we go home
wasn't uh isn't it carlos i can't that
does the voice right i always [ __ ] his
last name up i was a rock rock yeah yeah
yeah
so
i got home i'm very excited i'm getting
2 000 a month
now i confront some coke you know what
i'm saying i got some [ __ ] wiggle
room and [ __ ]
and one day out of nowhere i open up my
mailbox and there's a letter from
the advertising firm
that booked us
and in there there's a [ __ ] check
for scale they go joey
thank you very much
you know we're going to start airing
your commercial next week and i'm like
what
what [ __ ] commercial they're like we
kept you in the commercial you look
great blah blah blah i'm like oh [ __ ]
but i get a call no i didn't get a check
i'm lying to you
i just got a letter
then my buddy buzz calls me up
the sweetheart of a man
and he goes joey
did you get the letter and i go
yeah
and he goes [ __ ]
i guess we didn't get into the
commercial
what are you gonna do with your check
and i go oh nothing and he goes yeah
they didn't put me in the commercial i
got cut from it
i was in the commercial
and he got cut it was his original
commercial
so they sent him a separate check and
like left you in
a
and they gave me the commercial you know
i made
80 [ __ ] thousand dollars from august
5th to december 30. you should just say
80 8-0
8-80 000 i think i made the [ __ ] i made
140 000 off that commercial dog i
couldn't check the cash i couldn't cash
the checks fast forward 140 all in man
that's a great one those were everywhere
too everywhere well that was the first
set so i didn't know how popular they
were gonna be right so they kept [ __ ]
they didn't know when to shoot again
so my commercial ran during the world
series yeah
don't forget being in clark tennessee at
an army base and watching my commercial
on [ __ ] doing the world series and
[ __ ] you know
i was really excited about that but yeah
i ended up making 140 and then it was a
commercial of the year
and all the tv stations were voted in
and played a commercial so i would get a
check from that residuals on that [ __ ]
wow i got one
but then i was getting residuals on the
residuals damn
though you're a bad [ __ ]
that is a hell of a [ __ ] deal because
these days you don't even get that you
get like a buyout they don't even think
they give you points or anything anymore
you just get like a [ __ ] buy
out thank you very much see you later
man carlos must have made a
[ __ ] killing on that thing then
bro that dude bought two houses
i believe it
and then uh
interesting
because
i was getting to know my way around l.a
everybody was broke
we were all struggling you know ralphie
me
josh
you know the people that you see today
that are rocking and rolling if they
were around in 97 and 98 they were
[ __ ] struggling there was no whitney
there was no dalia
it was broken
was there duncan was there you know
a lot of [ __ ] it was it was
an interesting time in comedy in l.a
and i was just i don't know you know
you got to remember when i when i tell
you i made out in the 40 000 i didn't
have an apartment
it sounded like i was buying cars and
buying clothes
it was a party for me
my life was the comedy store
getting a grandma to a coke and ending
up in a hotel
sucking and [ __ ] with a dirty
waitress
or some chick from a show or something
it was just
it was fun
i remember i still remember
living with danny kelly for a while
on sunset which is like three blocks
before vista
and leaving his house with no money and
[ __ ]
walking into the gas station
and just putting my hand behind the
counter and taking a pack of cigarettes
there was no [ __ ] paying
i would just take a pack of cigarettes
you know i would take a [ __ ] soda
and it was just a scam every day and if
i didn't have money
josh would feed me
if josh didn't feed me ralphie may would
feed me
doug stanhope would feed you you know
looking back at it today i don't know
how he made it
don't know how he and then once me and
my girlfriend broke up the stripper
i really i really didn't have no where
to stay
so i lived in that car for a while
i uh stayed at josh's couch
and when i went on the road i got a
hotel that's when i could cut my
toenails and
buff out the skin under my nut sack
you know until then you're roughing it
but dog
i still remember getting coked out of
coaching horses and walking the business
i was a great rock and roll bar coaching
horse and just getting in my car and
pulling the seat back
and opening up the sunroof and putting a
blanket on and that was it that was my
world
and i was happy as [ __ ]
i was happy as [ __ ] as i was in it to
win it
you know i was [ __ ] in it to win it
but you know after she left i had more
more uh
action at the store
me and my girlfriend broke up like at
the end of 99.
and uh
you know i was living in a hotel on
shreve
where the whether without places where
people do comedy now you know that place
where people come from all over the
world and stay there
when you travel abroad oh the hostel
the hostel used to be a crack
that's where i was staying there when i
got the movie basketball
really
yeah so what happened was
i'm still with ken phillips i shoot the
commercial blah blah blah blah
and then ken phillips calls me one day
and he goes
there's an agency that's interested in
you i go who apa uta caa and he goes no
the coloring book
that's very kid date that was the name
of the company dog you want to add
insult to injury yeah
they were a [ __ ] kids agency
but she was growing to character actors
and i was her first adult
your resume was all different papers
like you had to make your resume on like
pink yellow blue
or orange paper and you had to beat me
that'd be different colors
it was a nightmare getting your i used
to go to dr phu you know the chinese guy
next to uh
next to uh the mexican restaurant they
used to make copies for you there
and i used to go in there and make 100
copies
she was a great lady she was black her
and her partner were black it was a
black agency
i mean i mean that's how bad things were
i couldn't even find a white agent to
sign up
there was a black agent that signed me
they were a kid's agent
did the hits just keep coming guys you
know i don't want you to think that
anybody gave me anything
so here i am with the coloring book i
still remember being behind the comedy
store and people like i'm with gersh
whatever i'm with the coloring books i
guess
[Applause]
[Laughter]
here i am with the [ __ ] coloring book
different colored [ __ ] resume
yes
people you run out of papers nah man
all these people complain this [ __ ] i'm
playing it all out for you right now
so i get a call one day
i got it ypd blue and i got a [ __ ]
call back wow
that's my first [ __ ] at the time that
was a groundbreaking show they were
breaking all the rules with camera work
and everything else that was great
so i had uh
i got in for libby goldstein
great lady
and i read for nypd blue and i got a
call back but i was too nervous
my hand was shaking at the call back
i didn't get it and then i got an
audition a few weeks later
for some [ __ ] tv show on fox
as some mexican [ __ ] gambler or
something
and i ate a bag of dicks and i had to go
all the way after the bosco building
at fox it's [ __ ] out there it's like
a eight mile [ __ ] walk
so i went to read i had this bumble
audition so i'm [ __ ] furious
i'm walking back to the bosco building
and as i'm walking past the door
a little lady with glasses pops out and
it's living
and she looks at me she goes joey are
you here for the audition
i guess
i was there for a different audition
i was walking past her door she just
happened to open and i was standing
there
i wasn't there for her audition i didn't
even know what the [ __ ] she was talking
about
i told you yeah she told me to sign in
and she gave me a sheet
and i'm reading this sheet over and over
and over and it's just two or three
lines well it was the movie baseball
yeah trey parker matt stone south park
guy
dog i read for it nobody said nothing i
walked out of there
furious because i had to walk eight
miles back to the car and i didn't book
nothing one day i'm at that [ __ ]
hostel
and i hear joey diaz
joey dears you got a phone call and i'm
like watching daytime television i go
joey diaz that's me
i go what he goes you got a phone call i
run downstairs and it's ken phillips and
he goes hey man congratulations
you booked that movie basketball i'm
like what are you talking about
[ __ ] you booked it you got to work on a
movie you've got to roll as a wreck
you're going to work for 5 500 a week
for a couple weeks i'm like what are you
[ __ ] talking about
and he goes here's the address you
got to be there tomorrow at 7.
and i went down there and it was a dream
come true jack dude you're living in a
hostel and
driving to a movie set
that's amazing
on an audition that
just was happenstance
literally you're not even there for that
no and i got the job and i had to join
sag and i didn't have a dime
i didn't have a [ __ ] dime
so i called danny robinson at apa and i
go danny
i'm a friend of doug stanhope you know i
knew danny and i go you got to help me i
got this movie
and i don't have the at that time it was
twelve hundred dollars
and they tapped hartley it's called they
they put you right in but they take that
12.
the first time they tap target the
second time you got to play the play oh
really i thought once you were in you
were in
oh yeah oh okay the first one is free
we'll let you get a free one the next
one a commercial movie tv show you got
to pay i didn't have no 12.50
i caught danny robinson he called me
back he goes i took care of it
the production company's gonna pay
i was like this ain't happening
so i [ __ ] go down there
and the first day i don't know what's
going on they give me scripts and [ __ ]
and wardrobe i don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about ryan
and finally i got to put it together you
know i was taking an acting class like
okay i see what i got to do
and every day i'm a comic dog i want to
work i want to get the [ __ ] out of here
whatever we want to do
so i would go down there and ask them am
i working today they go no no no come
back tomorrow but stay here until we
might need you today but the most thing
i remember is the roller skates
they gave us roller skate roller blades
and one day i said let me take a box of
these they were like size 14.
nobody's gonna know
and i stopped over by sports challenge
and they're like we'll give you a buck
20 for him
i gave him a panda i'll be back tomorrow
every day
[Laughter]
i would steal a [ __ ] uh
uh a pair of roller skates all right
everything
the 14s the 13s i kept the 12 for me
then i stole the 11s and i just went
backwards talk i didn't even notice it i
was just walking into the trailer taking
a box
and just putting it in my car and going
home stopping that ski chalet
one morning i'm out with jimmy two shoes
we could hook up like on a [ __ ]
saturday night and we're still going on
sunday
we're still going into monday morning
he drives me home at five
and i gotta be on the set at 7 30.
this is after four or five weeks on the
set nobody's even talking
i'm just going into the steel roller
skate type thing
i [ __ ] uh
get to the set they're like joey clean
up you're first up i'm drinking rum
vodka i got my sugar pills in me i got
more cocaine than colombia
and i gotta go [ __ ] shoot and i
remember that
by that time i'd even sold my skates
they're like what are your skates i
haven't had skates in weeks
they stole my skates and then they're
out there all the skates are missing
people would have signed
blisters because they had to put a size
7 on and [ __ ]
i [ __ ] that setup dog
and i thought
i thought they do with me that i thought
that roller skates
so when they called me six months later
they're like hey you made it to the
movie what name do you want i'm like
really
i made it to the movie
and then i had to pay a roll i was going
to wear roller skates for the premiere
just to bust their balls
didn't even bite because of something
for me
i didn't get any i had no roller skates
i'm lying to you guys but
i must have stolen
40 sets of [ __ ]
god
there was no [ __ ] roller skates left
when i got through that movie but
my daughter's walking in the door can we
do this again in two weeks
of course that's where we're at well
hold on let me let me just time stamp
this so
we ended it
we're in 1999
you just wrapped on the basketball or
you've just made it into the basketball
movie that's where we're gonna pick up
next time i love you thank you so much
is there anything you want to promote
plug anything at all that's my reefer
[ __ ]
laughing gas at the ice cream shop in
ventura they got a new weed called uh
rainbow ruts it's 37 percent
they'll [ __ ] kill you we got the best
bags of the business this is yours
yeah
it's called cocoa there's five different
flavors cocoa
rainbow ruts uh
sashimi
ooh
fenders
and there's another one i don't know
what's your favorite
tremendous
rainbow ruts rainbow ruts all right
brother boney stoney cottonmouth
all right are these all indica sativas
what are they
indicas and hybrids all right great i
love it i'm gonna go get some we're
gonna make a field trip out there i love
you brother i love you too and uh thank
you for doing this we'll pick it up
again go ahead
i'm very proud of you
i love you brother as always ryan
sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you